quarante ans de france de quarante ans
de carrière de michel drucker
on va faire un petit retour en arrière
on va se retrouver au temps où où tu
cherchais du boulot michel autant de la
rtf
on va faire une interview aux échos
écoute ça peut pas mieux tomber où est
ce que je t'ai à mener pour mes 40 ans
de telle est ma première apparition à la
télé ah ouais j'sais pas si tu cherches
qu'elles font peu cadré ce serait bien
qu'il y ait ça à l'image pendant qu'une
pause on voit la tronche que j'avais eu
ma première apparition alors il est à
gauche et françois jannin reporter
françois jannin oui je me souviens et
voilà la juge doit on dirait jean pierre
coffe est là et la cpi à 40 emplois et
faire notre photo vers l'autre photo
michel tout de suite ouais bon serge
cals phone call phones parle favor à je
sais ce que c'est il ya trente ans je
faisais déjà une émission qui s'appelait
rendez vous du dimanche avec françoise
coquet avec rémy graba qui en avait une
scripte charmant qui s'appelait
catherine barba ah oui tu as connu
script catherine de voici voici
françoise coquet un assistant longtemps
et rien d'autre et on voit là montant
qu'elle a et à côté de mon temps à
regarder
catherine barma et midi voix qui lui
catherine barma la fille de claude barma
qui on doit quelques unes des plus
belles pages de la télévision de service
public dont les rois mages de la grotte
de lascaux michel où il ya des victoires
donc ça veut dire gg 20 ans tu as tu as
20 ans oui aujourd'hui je reçois un
jeune qui aimerait bien faire de la
faire de la télé bonjour mon petit tu
t'appelles comment je m'appelle michel
drucker monsieur drucker ça marchera
jamais ça même michel sais pas d'où ça
marchera jamais non tu veux pas trouver
un nom là j'aurais bien plus et thierry
rolland roger couderc mais c'était déjà
pris alors tu veux faire la télé oui
pourquoi parce que je sais rien faire
d'autre pour l'instant je n'ai pas de
diplôme il paraît qu'à la télévision ils
n'ont pas de diplôme je sais que ça
gagne pas beaucoup d'argent la télé
michel
oui mais pour l'instant j'habite place
clichy avec ma mère juste en face chez
monsieur zitrone j'ai pas trop besoin
je prends le 80 tu as quoi comme
expérience
j'ai fait des petits boulots j'ai été
moniteur d'enfants difficiles j'étais
photographe de plage et j'ai été homme
de ménage à orly et je veux surtout pas
retourner affronter le tribunal de la
famille qui nature qui m'a toujours pas
pardonné de ne pas avoir fait d'études
on va voir oui tu te verrais bien dans
quel domaine le sport car je suis un
fondu de ça le divertissement ça te
dirait oui mais albert raisner ya guy
lux im et mortimer
ouais il ya des gens déjà très costaud
georgia jean nohain donc mais bon j'en
aurai en ce moment oui mais régionaux
t'aimerais présenter des variétés un
jour michel bassi un jour on me le
demande je sais qu'il ya une dame qui
m'a qui que j'aimerais rencontrer qu'
une grande productrice à la débloquer
michel arnaud michard nommé je la
connais très bien je te présente c'est
la productrice de gens qui sont avertis
elle était en plus elle a le bras long
puisqu'elle a été la maîtresse de
françois mitterrand bah oui et elle a eu
comme pianiste serge gainsbourg
j'aimerais bien la rencontre et bon bah
écoute ça ça peut s'arranger thème les
vedettes mon petit michel
j'aime les vedettes du sport j'aime
jacques anquetil j'aime fausto coppi et
j'aime par dessus tout raymond kopa est
juste fontaine est ce que tu sais que
les vedettes faut être gentil avec elle
pour qu'elle revienne régulièrement dans
des émissions tu as bien compris ça
ce bain et on m'a appris à être gentil à
la maison et à remercier beaucoup
devient ce côté provoc un peu destroy de
mon jeune frère qui a fait l'ena
dis moi tu t'es d'aidé faute à quoi
comme défaut michel je sais pas dire non
ouais je suis devrait émaner de belleval
je suis très impatient j'ai du mal à me
concentrer c'est pour ça que j'ai pas
fait d'études et puis j'ai un gros
défaut c'est que c'est que je je demande
à tous les jours à ma famille
qu'est ce que je ferai demain ouais je
suis obsédée par peur fait pas michel
t'en fais pas on va peut-être trouver
quelque chose pour toi je voudrais
absolument réussir quelques semaines un
drame un calme toi tu as l'air très
inquiet toi j'ai juste très inquiet ah
oui je suis très inquiet d'ailleurs
réduit ambitieux vous ne savez pas votre
calme et combien vous dites la vérité
puisque j'ai 20 ans déjà début d'ulcère
de l'estomac j'ai fait un zona ya trois
mois ah oui oui non mais faut que ça
s'arrête
est-ce que tu fumes monty michel non tu
fume pas non tu te drogue
non tu aimerais bien drogué non j'aime
tant de drogués monsieur c'est quoi ça
où il va prendre la température
s'il a un goût c'est normal
je n'ai triaire imagine le gars qui
zappe qui tombent si tant est qu'ils me
voient comme ça maintenant on est obligé
de faire un alcootest on est ça qui
plaît aussi c'est sûr ça c'est pour du
strauss et un petit contrôle jacques
oui mais voilà c'est de venir comment
aussi la bulle en bas avec jacques même
s'il a pas vu ça va changer de couleur
alors laurent c'est tout à fait normal
là je regarde le résultat il n'ya pas
bourré bourré très bourg et toi ces
greffes de foie
c'est très bien mais maintenant cinq ans
parle en fait de la télévision et non
mais j'espère justement rester plus de
50 arrêts si je peux rentrer à des
visions je voudrais rester très
longtemps et tu te vois ou dans 40 ans
eux à la télévision ah ouais tu crois
vraiment que tu feras encore de la télé
mon image et là rien
j'ai très bien puisque mes idoles à la
télévision léon zitrone chapatte couderc
et les autres ils ont 50 ans on vient
d'avoir 50 ans à la tête à une tête de
gendre idéal on a déjà dit non j'ai une
tête de gendre idéal
je sais pas c'est vrai si si si tu crois
si si moi je trouve que ça peut
simplement avec les filles ça marche
moyen mais il paraît que à la télévision
quand on se fait connaître ça marche
mieux là et tu vas voir oui tara piège à
filles maigres qui a demain dans ton
émission bon finish à ségolène royal la
présidente de région poitou charentes m2
les secousses et les accompagne la
campagne françois norfendre et avec
véronique sanson il en perd est
d'imaginer un petit scoop c'est je ne
savais pas qu'elle avait pratiqué le
piano donc elle est beaucoup plus non
mais quand tu joues c'est à dire est la
compagne véronique sens mais tout le
monde le sait ah bon je l'aimais manque
pas de charme ouais elle est pas mal et
la pêche michel elle est nulle son mari
non et bien son mari quand on le connaît
pas alors on n'imagine pas que c'est un
type extrêmement drôle qu'on le connaît
en france résiste
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu